this is Jessica McDonald standing in for
a viewer kihyun Chan there's religious
fanaticism and then there's Inquisitor
Aloysius from grateful a man so
excessively villainous his whole shtick
borders on farcical he appears when you
first step into the town square of the
city San Mateo's what draws your eye is
the site of a hulking woodland beast
howling in pain while tied to a stake in
an enormous burning pyre as a captured
Native Islander looks on helplessly when
asked why the creature and his people
are subjected to such cruelty the
Inquisitor bellows an odious response
about cleansing the corrupt souls of his
tribe then in one swift movement he
Yanks the Islanders head stabs the poor
soul with a knife and yells obscenities
about heresies into the sky that
uncomfortable scene is emblematic of the
plot in grateful its tales of
colonialism and political subterfuge are
tackled with such little nuance that
emerges on parody the island is where
face paints have heavy accents and
venerate the woodland beasts as deities
while the Cardinals bishops and
alchemists refer to them as savages that
need enlightenment or salvation
gratefull relies heavily on these kinds
of blunt narrative chirps for its
setting much in the same way that it
does on a very familiar open-world RPG
structure and while it's very easy to
lose yourself in its competent if
comfortable formula
it means the Grateful ultimately feels
unremarkable at best you play as the
charming diplomat de Sade from the
congregation of merchants who's in
charge of brokering peace between two
warring factions the Tali Mei a
theocratic nation that preach their
gospel heavily and want to convert as
many natives as possible even if it's by
force and to the bridge Alliance home to
a nation of alchemists who willed their
vast and incomparable knowledge of
science for political ends both factions
want to colonize a mystical island
called Tia for date which is brimming
with fantastical flora and fauna they as
well as the clans of indigenous people
who are resisting their incursions
seek your help for their own ends but
that's not all you also have something
you want from the island the cure for
the Malek or a mysterious plague
devastating your home beyond a vague
sense of awareness about its oppressive
legacy greed falls heavy-handed themes
never make way for anything more nuanced
or interesting sure it highlights the
exploitative behaviors of the Tali Mei
and bridge Alliance factions but their
actions are so mustache twirling
malicious that they become mere
caricatures of evildoers even your
companions and other characters are
cookie cutter emblems of their group
cieaura is the native princess who
wishes to seek peace for her clan petrus
is the religious t'lay may advisor with
tons of political savvy and curt is the
loyal headstrong mercenary whose stoic
demeanor can barely disguise his world
weariness God I'm not in need of your
protection no longer a child you know
greed Falls saving grace is that it's
role-playing systems are adequate and
the game's greatest strength is how well
it sticks to what is tried and tested it
features mechanical design that's common
in the genre but it's also savvy enough
to incorporate the best versions of
these elements at the beginning you're
given the choice of playing as one of
three character archetypes the melee
focused warrior the stealthy gunslinger
all the spell wielding tactician but
you're also given the flexibility to
break out of these standard classes
through an array of skill trees as you
progress through the game you can freely
invest hard earned points which opens up
a variety of methods you can approach
combat with and even how you resolve
quests as has become common in
open-world RPGs gratefull comes with a
crafting system and materials are in
abundance one constraint however is that
you can only craft upgrades to armor and
weapons you own this streamlines
crafting but also encourages you to seek
out better equipment meanwhile combat is
more than just a frenzied blur of swords
and gun play - you can make tactical
pauses to examine your enemies closely
change your target consider your combat
options or silently contemplate how
stunning your swashbuckling Buccaneer
looks in the heat of the action grateful
suffers from some bugs permit of systems
and even glaring spelling errors however
in everyone's eyes this island has great
promise and hikmah tis the city that
allows us to make good on that promise
the stealth mechanics are
unintentionally hilarious and do that
thing where enemies will treat your
companions as invisible romancing your
companions is also another thing you can
do in the game but the moves you need to
make to get into their hearts are so
perfunctory they're almost forgettable
it's also an easy process to save scum
and the ultimate reward is a not very
saucy bedroom cutscene in spite of the
game's blundering narrative issues is
still easy to get hooked into the rhythm
of exploring crafting brawling
investigating and interacting with a
host of characters and beasts while
getting lost among the beautiful lush
greenery of tier 4d challenging enemies
and boss fights are a particular treat
since you'll be able to pitch your
hard-earned combat abilities against
more formidable foes and touch within
the story as hackneyed as it is our
occasional glimpses of genuine humanity
such as de Sade's close relationship
with their cousin Constantine who's also
the governor of tier four day you got
your dose of bile to allow me to present
to you lady Mirage and to you my dear
lady my most trusted cousin but
ultimately because greed fall is so
cavalier about its colonialist themes
and because it plays it safe by sticking
so closely to the template of open-world
rpgs it doesn't really feel revelatory
in any way instead it's content to just
be another digital playground getting
lost in its familiar RPG loop is fun but
it's lack of nuance or innovation
prevents it from being truly remarkable
green blood how do you fare fine fine
[ __ ] is dead are you wounded I'm well